one of the really worrying trends in the
united states right now really under
this new modern republican party
call it whatever you want trumpian or
whatever the case may be
the thing is that facts truly do not
matter anymore
and rewriting history to suit whatever
point you're trying to make today
it has become a completely acceptable
means to an end it doesn't matter how
you rewrite history it doesn't matter
what lie you tell about the past
as long as it supports whatever point
you're trying to make today it's okay
for this modern republican party
here's one new example from the fourth
of july weekend
donald trump's former press secretary
kelly mcinanny appeared on fox news
and the context was making the point
that conservatives are victims and that
democrats are unpatriotic
and kaylee wildly claimed that the
founding fathers the main
founding fathers were all against
slavery
this is a lie it's just a big fat lie
and we're going to look at what she said
and the context was that democratic
congresswoman corey bush
said that july 4th is sort of a
celebration for white people
corey bush said when they say that the
fourth of july is about american freedom
remember
the freedom they're referring to is for
white people in the sense that we are
celebrating the anniversary of a country
which at year one the date that is being
celebrated was one
in which black people uh were enslaved
in the united states that's the context
okay let's look at what kaylee mcinanni
had to say about it
starting with you bill bennett the
haters never take a day off
from hating that is clear and they never
take a day off of getting the facts
wrong we know most of our forefathers
all of our main founding fathers were
against slavery recognize the evils of
it there's a great piece to that end on
heritage called 1776
not 16 19 but i'll leave it to you you
know they're so wrong on so much where
to begin
yes so that is completely untrue okay
that's really really really
not true let's actually go through this
because
there's there's an opportunity to
actually learn a little something here
the majority of the founding fathers of
the united states
owned slaves now you could say well they
owned them but they were against it
we're going to come back to that okay
but but they they were not
against it enough not to have their own
slaves now i'm talking about benjamin
franklin
john hancock john john jay thomas
jefferson james madison george
washington
and many others they they own slaves
some of the names you might not
recognize as readily
there were a few founding fathers that
did not own slaves
john adams and samuel adams in
massachusetts for example
thomas paine i don't believe is known to
have owned slaves okay
so when kaylee mcinanni says most of the
founding fathers were against
slavery mostly they owned slaves
now what is true is that over time
many founding fathers including some
that own slaves
started to recognize some problems with
slavery
some realized rightly that slavery was
antithetical to the concept of freedom
and liberty on which the u.s was
supposedly based
but some of them seemed more to be
thinking about it
almost like economically thomas
jefferson condemned the injustice of the
slave
trade in the initial draft of the
declaration of independence
but there are counterpoints about
whether did that mean he was against
slavery or did he just not like the
slave
trade as it was being carried out
internationally so
even that i mean i'm sure people will
write in and say no david that's super
clear it was either this or it was that
there's there's some ambiguity to it but
he owned slaves
and then you had some who really wanted
to change nothing about
whether slavery was federally legal and
just say it's a state issue
now if for example slave owner benjamin
franklin
slave owner owner benjamin franklin in
pennsylvania
supported anti-slavery causes but not
federally
you know if if south carolina wants to
keep having slaves well that's their
thing but in pennsylvania we shouldn't
have slaves necessarily so
to call that being anti-slavery again
that this is pretty nebulous in many
ways so the point here is
was the opinion on slavery of the
founding fathers
maybe more complex than they were either
for it or against it
absolutely did some founding fathers
have
seemingly inconsistent positions on
slavery absolutely
did some of them change their views on
slavery over time yes
no doubt about it but is kaylee mcinanni
right when she says most of the founding
fathers were against slavery
no that's a complete and total lie and
the point here of what kaylee mcinanni
did was simply
to try to attack corey bush by saying
when corey bush says july 4th really
celebrates freedom for white people
because
at the time black people were enslaved
kaylee wants to say
well no we're the the founding fathers
were all against slavery
and um that is simply inaccurate and so
her entire defense
falls apart now whether you agree
that july 4th is a pro-slavery holiday
or a celebration of an era when there
was slavery
that that's a debate that's a debate you
can have and you can say well okay yes
we're celebrating the anniversary of a
date at which
there was slavery we no longer have that
we can still recognize that this is a
milestone in the existence of the
country without being in agreement with
all the things that the country did at
the time
right then you're in the weeds you're in
the details but kaylee mcinanny is just
wrong
and this is the exact type of little
pithy talking point
that the average fox news viewer will
never investigate and will simply start
to repeat and repeat and repeat it's sad
more than anything else
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video